ever wondered what happened to the
heroes of Independence Day once the
credits rolled well wonder no more the
first trailer for the sequel has been
released to tell us all about it Will
Smith's got bigger fish to fry VIN
saving the world but don't worry because
the man the legend Jeff Goldblum is back
I'm Lucy and welcome to this sir
gamespot news update so spoilers the
ending of a 19 year old movie but at the
end of Independence Day we defeat the
invading alien forces and then the world
celebrates wildly but then what happens
well according to the official movie
plot description we always knew they
were coming back after independence day
redefined the event movie genre the next
epic chapter delivers global spectacles
on an unimaginable scale using recovered
alien technology the nations of Earth
have collaborated on an immense defense
program to protect the planet but
nothing can prepare us the aliens
advanced an unprecedented force only the
ingenuity of a few brave men and women
can bring our world back from the brink
of extinction we know that Jeff Goldblum
Bill Pullman brent Spiner and Josh
returned from the first movie appearing
alongside newcomers Liam Hemsworth
Jessie Usher Michael Monroe and feel
award but where's the fresh print well a
viral site for resurgence reveals the
fate of Captain Steve Hiller spoilers
obviously but according to the fiction
Colonel Hiller died on April 27 2007
during a military exercise gone wrong
wild test piloting the earth space
defenses first alien hybrid fighter an
unknown malfunction causes the untimely
death Colonel Hiller hellas valla in the
war of 96 made him a beloved global icon
who's selfish assault against the alien
mothership led directly to the enemy's
defeat he is survived by his wife
jasmine and son Dylan resurgence day
opens in theaters on jun 24 2016 so what
did you make of the trailer are we ready
for more alien invasions let me know in
the comment box below don't forget i'm
on twitter at Lisa James games and for
all the latest make sure you keep a
gamespot